[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
transformation
thank you very much thank you very much
prime minister
dear kieran
thank you for the very warm welcome
um
this is the start of the day here
i'm very much looking forward to
our visit at the university of sofia
and i know that at this university this
is the place where bulgaria's excellence
is shining
and we've been speaking a lot the two of
us on the need to combine
the scientific excellence
with the business sector
to develop products
that then can really deliver market
value
and i know that there are projects that
outstanding innovative concrete projects
for example the satellite technology
where we have a lot of expectations in
such innovation is instrumental to keep
our economy and our society resilient
and competitive
so i'm very much looking forward to see
innovation made in europe
and
this is innovation that is homegrown it
is for secure technologies for example
so an invaluable asset in a more and
more turbulent world
this of course requires
investment
and this is why we're here today
next generation eu
our big recovery plan
worth 800 billion euros
that we put up
to modernize and reshape our continent
for the future generations after the
pandemic
now with next generation eu
we have three priorities the one is the
european green deal
very dominant at the moment being the
topic of clean energy of course because
it's not only clean energy but also
secure energy independent energy good
for the climate but also good for our
independence
the second topic is the digitalization
and the third topic we are investing in
is equipping our societies to be
stronger and to be more resilient
so today
the european commission is giving its
green light to bulgaria's recovery and
resilience plan
it is an outstanding plan almost 60
percent
of the plan supports the green
transition
this is significant and of course it is
most welcome
because we need bulgaria on board
on the road towards climate neutrality
in the european union
and if i may
quote a few
examples for the substance that is in
this plan
under the umbrella of the european green
deal it's for example decarbonizing
power generation with binding caps on
emissions from coal
it is scaling up renewables and energy
storage very important topic
it's reforming the electricity market
investment in smart grids
and we all know in these times how
important that is it is
investing
in increased interconnections with
romania and greece very important to to
diversify the energy supply that we have
so not to be any more dependent on
russian coal
gas and oil but to diversify towards
reliable suppliers
and almost 1 billion euro goes for
energy renovation and large investments
in clean mobility including electric
cars
so you see from the examples this is
outstanding
the second topic
is the digital transition here the plan
sure that
public services
are more accessible and more efficient
through digitalization
the plan makes sure that there's a
connection throughout the country with
the expansion of high-speed internet in
rural areas
and it creates the right conditions for
the developed development of 5g this is
so important really to have the whole
country connected digitalized you know
that this is one of the core topics for
the future
and
almost 450 million euros will focus on
equip and equipping
bulgarian students
and bulgarian workers with the right
digital skills for the jobs of the
future
thus the bulgarian plan meets the very
demanding conditions and criterias we
have jointly established
so it combines investment for the green
and digital transition
with reforms
for um of structural challenges that we
have
one
hallmark is the strengthening of the
minimum income scheme
and the support to the most vulnerable
i think this is also a very important
topic
or it addresses
the plan addresses the shortages in
health care
professionals across the country
with the pandemic we have learned how
important it is to have these front line
workers
and it creates stronger institution with
broad anti-corruption measures you
mentioned it
and i personally am very glad
to see in this plan that you also put a
focus on children
children's access to education
so the possibility for four years old
and
older children to have preschool
education is something which is defining
their future life the access to
education
our approval today is an important
milestone towards the disbursement
indeed of 6.3 billion euros over the
next years this is 10 of the gdp
but i would say this is by no means the
end of a journey it's the beginning of
the journey there's a lot of good work
ahead of us
and of course the europe the commission
stands ready always to support
but before i hand you
the commission's assessment
allow me
to thank you
and to thank the bulgarian people for
your outstanding generosity
towards the ukrainian people
that are fleeing the war in ukraine
you have welcomed more than 130 000
refugees in your country
many of them are staying
and with no certainty on the end of the
conflict
it is important that we mobilize all our
efforts
to help the refugees and to help the
internally displaced
you know that we have flexibilized
european funds
so that they are immediately accessible
for you
to cover expenditures expenditures for
the refugees
there's another step we will take
with the
online pledging event that we call stand
up for ukraine
i convened it together with prime
minister justin trudeau of canada
and it will take place in warsaw this
saturday
we want to rally the world
to pledge for ukrainian refugees
in ukraine and outside ukraine and i
know i can count on bulgaria's
contribution to this global solidarity
effort
you do a lot here in bulgaria and i want
it to be honored so
with no further ado i'll hand over the
commission's assessment for bulgaria's
next generation eu plan for your prime
minister thank you so much
thank you
thank you so much
indeed on these two topics the plan is
really good
um if you it's one of the most green
plants that we have uh in the european
union and i think it's now the 23rd plan
that
um the commission is approving
with 60
of the plan going into the european
green deal with all the topics i've just
been
describing
so very important is you have a
trajectory to cut greenhouse gas
emissions
by 40 percent by 2025 this is very
ambitious but it's also very necessary
so congratulations on that
you triple power generation from
renewables by 2026
and
you have a phase phase-out coal-powered
plants by 2038 so there's a real
structure real plan behind it
to cut emissions on one hand and on the
other hand to invest heavily into
renewables and of course the storage
capacities the battery capacities that
are so important i was mentioning also
the interconnections that in my view are
very important because you have to
diversify
the possibility to have access for
example to pipeline gas a very important
topic so it's one of the most ambitious
plans we have
what the european green deal is
concerned
the second part of your questions is
indeed you address
two of the
main major topics that are necessary in
the cvm for example this is a big step
forward
there's the reform of the
anti-corruption commission
is one big pillar that is important and
the other important pillar is the
accountability of the prosecutor general
so two big required reform steps within
the cvm so a big step forward also to
achieve your goals
[Music]
[Music]
so there's a very clear plan and goals
described in the rrp what this topic is
concerned
um the the main overarching headline
here is accountability
and this is in every system important
that there are checks and balances
with power
accountability has to go hand in hand
these are the reform steps that are
necessary and that are laid down in the
plan explicitly
[Music]
um
so
i assume your question was concerning
the
request from russia to pay in rubles
did i get it right yeah
indeed
important is how the contracts are
and the contracts are very clear the
contracts say contracts say the payment
has to be either in euros
here for example in the european union
or in dollars
right now we are looking very
intensively at the decree
but at first sight it is very clear that
we stick to the contracts and this
recommends
uh and it said uh laid out very clearly
that the payments will be in euros and
in dollars and not in rubles
i think it is very important
that we have a clear analysis
of the presidential decree that was
issued a few days ago that's the process
we are in and as long as we have not
[Music]
set the common position of the european
union rest assured
contracts have to be followed and the
contract is in euro and in dollar
the diversification
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
the
foreign
um
i think um a final answer
is
absolutely what this plan the plan is
outstanding
um what the milestones and targets are
concerned for all the member states
perhaps it's necessary to explain that
for all the member states
we agreed at this big 800 billion next
generation eu plan under two conditions
there is investment
but the investment has to come with
reform
and
we look at
the reform necessities in the so-called
european semester
which is a process where the european
commission looks over years since years
in depth in the different member states
what is the main requirement for reform
and therefore every member state
has to fulfill specific reforms
tailor-made reforms for the member state
and of course the investment
and here the reforms are as we have
described
so like in every other member state you
deliver the reform there is the
disbursement of money
it's like a good contract
and
as as you mentioned the different topics
here it is important
that indeed the the reforms are done and
it is important that the contracts are
served
and we have discussed all these topics
together
um i wanted to commend bulgaria
finally not only what the refugees are
concerned but also i want to commend you
in all the support that it is here
in the region what our
good neighborly
conditions are concerned
and here i think it is also important to
have a clear approach
to the tasks ahead of us
i want to remind all of us
that in 2020
2020
the european council took a major
decision
to step forward and to say
now it's time
and we promise to start negotiations
accession negotiations with north
macedonia and albania
the european council
concluded on that this is a binding word
and i think it's now important that we
deliver together
and for you i want to say very clearly
the topic of protecting minorities is a
core value
of the european union it's a core value
it's an article two
of our treaties very prominent
so yes this is an important topic
it is being taken care of in the process
and i think it is important now that we
deliver on our promise in these
difficult times towards our neighbors
these times are very special and very
difficult and very turbulent and they
will determine the future of europe
nothing will be
the same anymore as it was before the
war after the war
and to keep promises to our friends and
partners who count on us is very
important
therefore i count on bulgaria
that you will skillfully steer the
process and i know that you're able to
do that many thanks for hosting me here
today
it has been a very good experience i'm
looking forward now to see the
university
thank you